bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le premier épisode d'un geste pour
la planète
aujourd'hui on va commencer par vous
parler de vous moi non de mois bah non
de mois non non de vous et plus
précisément de ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
de vous et qui ressort de temps en temps
de ce que vous produisez un somme
oui oui on va parler pipi caca
[Musique]
saviez vous que votre urine qu il ne
vous viendrait probablement pas à l'idée
de boire contient pourtant de précieux
nutriments du phosphore de la zot du
potassium
mais aujourd'hui ce que nos toilettes
chasse à grands renforts d'eau potable
n'atterrit plus que dans les égoûts et
les stations d'épuration où il faut
ensuite tous traités en plus ces
stations d'épuration et met des tonnes
de gaz à effet de serre
autant que le trafic aérien à l'échelle
mondiale et ses stations sont parfois
surchargées elles ont bien du mal à
faire face à nos besoins sans mauvais
jeu de mots et lorsqu'elles sont
surchargés elle déverse donc des eaux
encore trop riche en phosphates et en
azote dans les rivières
le problème c'est qu'ils produisent des
algues indésirables qui menacent la
biodiversité animale et végétale dans
nos cours d'eau alors comment soulager
les stations d'épuration et réorienter
le potentiel fertilise acteurs de lure
in là où on en a vraiment besoin
on en revient donc à nos toilettes pour
faciliter le recyclage de ces nutriments
le plus simple serait de commencer par
séparer les déchets des la cuvette
alors comment en art est temps de faire
des pays debout
coup dur c'est tout pour le savoir
direction toulouse ici des scientifiques
ont un projet pour le moins ambitieux
développer les toilettes du futur les
chercheurs ont eu une idée toute simple
mais ingénieuse traiter les déchets
produits par notre corps comme tous les
autres déchets en les séparant à la
source sur ce prototype de toilette
conçu par les scientifiques toulousains
une grille de séparation permet
d'évacuer directement lui rinne par un
canal différent de celui suivi par les
excréments
un peu comme on le fait chez vous quoi
le plastique c'est là le carton c'est là
le caca c'est là nous oui enfin pour que
ça marche a quand même une contrainte il
faudrait que ces messieurs accepte enfin
de faire pipi à 6,6 pas trop demander et
l'autre truc ingénieux dans le système
conçu par nos ingénieurs toulousain
c'est qu'on arrête de gaspiller l'eau
potable au lieu d'être emporté par une
chasse d'eau qui utilisent entre 3 et 9
litres d'eau potable
les déchets sont évacués sous vide
c'est-à-dire par de l'air est un tout
petit peu d'eau comme dans les avions
dans les trains des endroits où l'on
manque d'eau comme sur terre quoi un
bref grâce à ses toilettes intelligentes
on peut récupérer l urine pur propre
comme on les aime
il ne reste plus ensuite qu'à en
extraire la substantifique moelle
autrement dit les fameux nutriments ah
ouais mais du coup ça se mange non james
est juste pour les plans là ah ok et là
encore les chercheurs ont développé une
méthode innovante et efficace pour
produire de l'engrais directement à
partir d'une urines récupérés lors
d'événements à forte concentration
humaine et urinaires les festivals
alors comment on fait on verse lui rinne
dans une centrifugeuse
on y ajoute du magnésium et hop on lance
la machine on obtient de l'astre vite
cela permet de créer un produit
phosphorer en grains qui ressemble
beaucoup aux engrais classique et qui
peut d'ores et déjà être utilisé comme
fertilisant
mais si vous avez à peu près suivie
jusqu'ici vous allez me demander
oui mais là zot i ly ou la zot je sais
bien on pose cette question dix fois par
jour pour récupérer la zot on a recours
à une technique particulièrement
novatrice la chimie aux options
transmembranaire août et mcs voilà à
bientôt
abonnez vous bon d'accord je vais
essayer de vous l'expliquer la zot de
lure insee naturellement transformer en
ammoniaque
avec cette technique on fait passer
cette ammoniac sous forme de gaz à
travers une membrane pour pouvoir
récupérer la zot
il est ensuite capté à l'aide d'une
solution d'acide sulfurique produisant
ainsi une solution de sulfate d'ammonium
et ça ça ne vous dit peut-être rien mais
c'est un fertilisant comme ce qu'on peut
trouver dans le commerce mais en propre
d'autant plus que les engrais chimiques
que nous utilisons actuellement dans
l'agriculture intensive sont très
énergivores et surtout issus de
ressources fossiles
autrement dit pas super top pour la
planète et nous la planète
on y tient un peu mais soyons encore
plus concret ce n'est peut-être pas pour
tout de suite mais dans quelques années
on pourra peut-être fournir paris en
pain grâce à du blé fertilisé par le
toilettes ou encore alimenter un
festival en bière avec l'uriné de
l'édition précédente
nouvelle bien merci non